let me try
something which i hope will be a bit
easier
from
argentina
it's pretty early in argentina
i think it should be
okay
a6
is highly surprising
you gotta think before i think about
what my last move was about before you
make a move
because yeah he wanted a6 because he
wanted bishop
c5 and which based on let run but
when
a pawn on e5
is hanging it's usually a good idea to
protect it
because now i am just upon up with uh
a winning position
wow
and that's the first case today of
my camera falling down
which is i
think a lot of people's
favorite part
you can see something on the back of my
computer
now
now you can see my
my hand and
soon enough you'll be able to see me as
well
so he's done well after
dropping
upon developing the pieces on good
squares
now i just wanna
go bishop d3 trade some more pieces
a3
knight c2 doesn't work that knight is
trapped
[Music]
and
yeah you had to have to take but
it's not gonna help him
and i feel like it it's fairly likely
that i'm gonna get the easy win that i
desired
where am i knight f5 i suddenly realized
loses pawn to work h3
i have to go back
wow
that was embarrassing
[Music]
butch
alas
i'm still a piece up so
complain too much i should not
rook c2 just trying to be solid
protecting
some squares along the second rank
next i think i want to go b4 c5 perhaps
to shut in his bishop
bishop c1
could be
on the cards
95 it's the rook where is it gonna go
i don't know
with p3 rookie two hitting the rook
again
and
the
sailing looks to be a plane
as far as i can see
just take back with the rook why not
just no threats
i gotta say this guy's been playing
pretty pretty well after
blundering the
blundering the pawn on move four but
yeah blundering upon and move four is
pretty
hard to come back
from unfortunately
well fortunately for me
check
well that's a three piece and i shall
say thank you
yeah
not too much to comment on
another fork always love that
more material
and uh just give me a couple seconds i
feel like it's getting a bit dark
gold turn on some lights
and as i live in norway